petit plus de noël et tout j'espère que
vous allez bien que vous avez passé un
très bon réveillon de noël
si vous le souhaitez si vous faites est
pas j'espère que vous allez bien aussi
il ya un peu plus d'une semaine j'ai
sorti une vidéo sur comment créer une
habitude et sur le fait que j'ai mérité
tous les jours de l'année pendant un an
et les retours ont été vraiment plus
cool que ce à quoi je m'attendais si
vous les descriptions jeu pas pourquoi
je suis choquée elle est en descriptions
la vidéo elle est à 140 tribus et il ya
des centaines de commentaires genre
vraiment trop cool des gens qui se sont
sentis motiver des gens qui ont envie de
changer des choses des gens qui ont
apporté des trucs qui ont apporté des
précisions sur eux comment ils vivent et
les habitudes et c'est donc logique que
ce serait dommage de s'arrêter là et que
voilà dans quelques jours là c'est le
nouvel an et ce serait très approprié de
parler de nouvelle résolution
plus spécifiquement parce que dans la
vidéo précédente je parlais juste de
d'habitude et crée des habitudes peut se
faire à n'importe quel moment de l'année
surtout ne limitait pas ça forcément aux
résolutions
dans cette vidéo donc on va parler plus
précisément des résolutions on va voir
aussi qu' il ya un truc est un concept
de liste de nouvelles résolutions etc
on va aller parcouru ensemble et on va
voir pourquoi
schouppe et sa résolution dans ce genre
de truc ça n'a aucun sens et c'est quoi
le vrai intérêt d'une résolution
pourquoi on prend une résolution les
listes de nouvelle résolution
avant ça existe ainsi vous tapez 20
nouvelles résolutions
surtout en anglais vers ces détails
présents chez certains youtuber et
youtube buzz un peu inspirational j'ai
rien contre l'inspiration elle enfin
parfois mais dans l'absolu rien c'est
bien d'être senti inspiré et c'est
parfois il faut savoir ranger son
cynisme accepté se prendre des grosses
vagues de love et bienveillance
je sais c'est pas évident c'est pas
toujours évident ces listes me rend ouf
et donc je vous ai sélectionné 20 idées
de nouvelles résolutions qu'on retrouve
dans ce genre de liste j'ai pu gêner
différentes pistes etc
parce que parfois j'ai trouvé des trucs
genre prendre ses rendez vous chez le
docteur ou monter les escaliers cuisine
est un truc nouveau chaque semaine lire
plus
rejoindre un club dépend du club
j'imagine boire moins d'alcool avant une
plante voit une plante faire du yoga
avec son partenaire
vraiment c'était ça à faire du vieux
avec son partenaire pas en faire du yoga
seul vraiment apparemment ce nul faut
vraiment le faire avec son partenaire
bios et sérieuse du montage
j'arrête les gling gling gling va
compris j'appelle ma doit revoir ses
héros
arrêtez de procrastiner arrêter de fumer
regardez moi la télé
trouver l'amour c'est mon préféré c'est
vraiment le plus simple je pense en
nouvelle résolution
ranger plus apprendre une nouvelle
langue être plus organisés arrêter des
fortes à tenir un journal intime méditer
s'hydrater plus et ça me rappelle
quelqu'un pas écouté des livres audio
pendant le sport ce faire un budget et
le tenir avant faire du sport tout
simplement et le souci de ces listes
c'est que non seulement c'est difficile
de trouver une résolution qui te
correspond vraiment non plus c'est pas
un truc un peu c'est sait trop quoi un
côté presque culpabilisant genre voilà
juste serait la personne parfaite si tu
faisais tout ça je bref c'est pas fait
pour ça je pense les résolutions et je
pense que c'est une mauvaise piste ce
genre de liste parce que c'est quoi le
vrai intérêt des résolutions le vrai
intérêt des résolutions en fait
paradoxalement c'est pas la résolution
en tant que tel et c'est pas un bon sens
le changement que ça va engendrer je ne
pense pas que ce soit ça le vrai intérêt
des résolutions je pense que le vrai
intérêt des résolutions c'est plutôt
faire un bilan
un petit peu sur sur soi est plutôt
savoir qu'est ce qu'on a envie de
changer mais ce qui compte ce n'est pas
tant le fait de le changer mais le fait
d'avoir mis le doigt sur un truc qui ne
nous correspond pas vraiment c'est ça le
but
des résolutions donc là il vous reste
quatre jours pour faire le bilan sur soi
est normalement vous allez c'est pas un
truc un déclic
quelque chose qui est genre paf un
tableau et c'est ça peut marcher comme
ça mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
progressif beaucoup plus dans le temps
et on le sait quoi globalement les trucs
qu'on veut changer les trucs qui nous
plaisent pas on le sait quoi
il faut juste un moment lucidité ne pas
se mentir à soi même et on a tous des
mécaniques différentes là dessus on a
tous des mécaniques de bonheur
différentes par exemple sur certaines
personnes pour faire du sport le matin
et ça donne la pêche pour la journée et
c est bien pour plein de gens faire du
sport le matin c'est la pire idée parce
que ben ça les fatigue et du coup ils
sont encore moins
c'est un exemple tout bête mais c'est
pour vous dire que souvent on associe
certaines habitudes et certains profils
qu'ils sont ce qu'on vise
sauf qu'il ya plein de chemin différent
en fait pas rêver à ce profil là je vois
que ces listes m'embête parce que je
sens que ça enferme les gens dans une
sorte de modèle
je pense qu'une bonne résolution c'est
une résolution qui est unique en fait et
qui vous correspond vraiment bout j'ai
terminé par vous donner ce que je vous
conseille pour les résolutions déjà il
ya un truc qui a été dit dans les
commentaires de la vidéo précédente
qu'effectivement en faire trop trop
d'habitudes différents trop de
résolution etc
c'est contre-productif donc souvent se
limite à un mois j'ai bien envie de vous
donner deux types de résolution donc
l'idée c'est d'en prendre un de chaque
d'abord une résolution qui est très
spécifique pas comme regarder - la télé
ou pas comme lire plus un truc vraiment
spécifique c'est-à-dire on parle de
minutes on parle de nombre de pages on
parle vraiment on est spécifique et
notre révolution qui elle est plus large
genre par exemple prend plus de temps
pendant ces hyper large c'est mais c'est
une gamme line en fait c'est un cap
un cap que je veux suivre dans mon année
qui fait que ça va s'appliquer de plein
de manières différentes
même pour moi voilà c'est ça c'est voir
un cap et un tube très précis plus et
précis plus c'est facile mais c'est
moins agréable et vous avez moins
d'opportunités donc c'est pour ça que je
trouve ça cool de m inquiet précis et un
qui est large d'ailleurs si vous les
partagez vos idées de résolution que
soient précises ou large
n'hésitez pas à le faire en commentaire
parce qu'en plus ça peut potentiellement
aider les gens qui sont un peu plus
perdu même si je le rappelle ces
personnes là que ce qui compte c'est de
trouver des
mission qui vous corresponde vraiment
vous la dernière chose c'est
concentrez-vous sur le chemin est pas
forcément la destination dans la vidéo
précédente je disais que c'était cool de
visualiser l'objectif fixé
c'est vrai ça c'est pour se motiver à
créer une habitude dans le cadre des
résolutions
gardez en tête que votre résolution en
elle même doit avoir un intérêt et que
c'est pas que l'objectif qui doit être
intéressante parce que ce n'est pas
l'objectif que vous allez vivre c'est la
résolution que vous allez vivre donc
trouver une résolution que vous pouvez
apprécier sur le moment pour elle même
c'est la fin de l'année 2019 c'est la
dernière vidéo de l'année je pensais que
c'est la précédente mais en fait non
c'est le monte tellement plein de
surprises c'est ouf
c'est dingue vraiment pour moi c'est une
année vraiment intéressante tant au
niveau personnel que professionnel sur
youtube j'ai sorti ma vidéo préférée je
pense ou en tout cas vraiment elle est
dans le top 2 en tout cas elle est dans
le top 3 c'est sûr c'est ma vidéo sur le
liban et les réfugiés au liban sur les
ai pas vus vraiment regarder la c j'ai
l'impression que j'ai donné les gens le
meilleur de moi même
dans cette vidéo autre truc important
qui s'est passé pour moi cette année
c'est que la chaîne de l'antisèche donc
cette chaîne où je vous fais des
conseils pour le brevet le bac sur
toutes les matières écrites avec des
profs et où cette chaîne à la dépasser
ma chaîne principale dont je crois
qu'elle est à peu près de 460 ou 470
mille abonnés donc c'est vraiment trop
cool et vous êtes nombreux à me
remercier pour le bac ou le brevet que
ce soit dans la rue soit par messager
qui cédera donc vraiment merci beaucoup
ça me fait vraiment plaisir de vous
rendre service
après j'ai un petit peu réfléchi aussi à
ce que je voulais faire or de youtube
parce que le irl me manque un peu
parfois donc sont aussi en quoi on se
revoit l'année prochaine ah oui j'ai
reçu aussi un commentaire qui revient
souvent c'est genre parle-nous du fait
de méditer tous les jours qu est ce que
ça a changé par nous la méditation quoi
je le ferai je le ferai en 2020 promis
qu est d'ailleurs en 2002 aurait un
autre projet que je suis en train
d'essayer de mettre en place sur ma
chaîne youtube qui va venir
je peux pas vous en parler mais ça fait
tout s'arrête
j'aurais dû love et de la pisse ciao